SALVO FOR SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING
TO NEED TO RUN TO THE CENTER TO
HAVE A SHOT AT TAKING DOWN THE
HIGHLY POPULAR RON DeSANTIS.
>> BACK TO ABORTION.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR ALL OF YOU, A
REALLY INTERESTING MOMENT FROM A
SOUTH CAROLINA REPUBLICAN, A
LAWMAKER WHO HAS HAD WHAT SOUNDS
LIKE A CHANGE OF HEART ABOUT HIS
VOTE FOR A VERY RESTRICTIVE LAW
IN SOUTH CAROLINA BECAUSE HIS
EYES HAVE BEEN OPENED TO WHAT
THIS MEANS FOR WOMEN.
HE HEARD THE STORY OF A YOUNG
WOMAN, 19 YEARS OLD, WHO WAS
HAVING A MISCARRIAGE, AND THE
DOCTORS AT THE HEALTH CLINIC
COULD NOT TREAT HER BECAUSE OF
THIS NEW LAW, AND TOLD HER THAT
SHE WAS GOING TO HAVE TO GO HOME
AND SUFFER ON HER OWN.
HERE'S HIS THOUGHTS TODAY.
>> THE DOCTOR TOLD ME AT THAT
POINT THERE'S A 50% CHANCE,
WELL, FIRST, SHE'S GOING TO PASS
THIS FETUS IN THE TOILET.
SHE'S GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT ON HER OWN.
THERE'S A 50% CHANCE, GREATER
THAN 50% CHANCE THAT SHE'S GOING
TO LOSE HER UTERUS.
THERE'S A 10% CHANCE THAT SHE
WILL DEVELOP SEPSIS AND HERSELF
DIE.
THAT WEIGHS ON ME.
I VOTED FOR THAT BILL.
THESE ARE AFFECTING PEOPLE.
>> I MEAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT HIS SORT OF CANDOR, NUMBER
ONE, AND IF THAT WILL SOMEHOW
PAY OFF AND THE FACT THAT NOW
THIS IS COMING HOME TO ROOST AND
THEY'RE ACTUALLY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS CAN HURT WOMEN.
>> WELL, IT'S A GUTTING
TESTIMONY, AND I'M GRATEFUL TO
HIM FOR SHARING IT.
LISTEN, I'M A PRO LIFE AMERICAN,
BUT MY PARTY TRADITIONALLY
ALWAYS BELIEVED IN EXCEPTIONS
FOR RAPE, INCEST AND THE LIFE OF
THE MOTHER.
WHAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT, THAT
WOULDN'T COME INTO PLAY IF YOU
HAD THE BOUNDARIES IN EFFECT.
WHAT I WOULD SAY, IS MOST OF OUR
EUROPEAN FRIENDS HAVE
LIMITATIONS ON ABORTION, EVEN IF
IT'S 14 OR 15 WEEKS.
THAT POSITION IS NOT OUTSIDE OF
THE MAINSTREAM IN THE U.S.
80% OF AMERICANS BELIEVE IN
ACCESS BUT ALSO SOME
LIMITATIONS, BUT THIS VE